you've probably seen what's happened in
the u.s capitol
here's a quick rundown to help you make
sense of it all george the capital
usa these are president donald trump
supporters storming the capitol building
where the us congress sits
[Applause]
get down under your chairs if necessary
inside lawmakers were holding
a joint session to certify electoral
college votes to confirm joe biden as
the next president of the united states
the world watching what america looked
like today
that's definitely tear gas
[Music]
okay so what happened well trump has
never conceded the november election
he says it was stolen but his lawyers
haven't been able to prove the
allegations of widespread fraud
ahead of congress meeting to certify the
presidential vote
trump called on his supporters to head
to washington dc for a rally
and many answered his call
on wednesday morning the crowd was
growing outside the capitol building
by around noon trump came out to speak
to supporters outside the white house
here's part of what he said we will stop
the steal after this
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you to the capitol
and that's exactly what they did but
trump stayed home
by two o'clock there were thousands of
protesters and some eventually broke
through the barriers
got inside the building and congress
stopped certifying the votes
hours later lawmakers had been evacuated
at one point the trump team put out a
video of the president telling
protesters to leave
but he didn't back down on his
unsubstantiated fraud allegations
i know you're paying i know you're hurt
we had an election
that was stolen from us but you have to
go home now
that video was actually taken down by
twitter and youtube because of its
potential to incite violence
in the early hours of thursday morning
lawmakers returned to congress and at 3
40 am
certified joe biden as president-elect
by that time
four people were dead many more were
injured and at least
50 had been arrested lots of people
condemned the violence democrats and
republicans
but what's really interesting is how all
of this has exposed a growing split in
the republican party
while senator ted cruz was calling on
republicans to block the certification
of votes from
biden republican heavyweights like
lindsey graham who've always backed
trump
we're saying things like this trump and
i have we've had a hell of a journey
i hate it being this way all i can say
is count me out enough is enough so what
happens now
well some people want vice president
mike pence to invoke the 25th amendment
of the u.s constitution
to remove trump and make pence president
for now
so many who have remained loyal to the
president
are seriously questioning whether he
should continue
as president of the united states for
the next two weeks
democrats and republicans are already
accusing trump of being mentally unsound
others are talking about impeachment
thing is trump still has time in office
and can still use the powers of the
presidency until biden takes over
that happens on january 20th by thursday
morning trump promised there will be an
orderly transition
but some people are still worried a lot
can happen
between now and inauguration day